Hi, I'm Orisha fair. Uh,
I have a special on Netflix called double negative and a podcast called skeptic
tank. And I'm here to answer the inner.
[Inaudible].
If you could. Why? I thought I was going to say, if you could wipe and I'm like,
yeah, I do wipe you wipe one group of people off the earth. Who would it be?
Italians. The worst of the whites. It's no question.
I've already had this thought many times and I would do it instantly.
Anytime you come into contact with an Italian,
it's gonna be a negative interaction for you.
The only good Italians and one who deny their heritage,
who try to hide it the way Jews didn't the Holocaust, would you have a sexy,
their cousins went Powerball. Here's the problem though.
I have one super hot cousin that had already considered having sex with.
So like, uh, you're adding power of all of that. You know what I mean?
This is already a go. Yeah, it's a win-win.
I went to the Powerball $18. I'm in, if you were to be murdered,
who is the most likely suspect? Oh, good question. Who would kill me, dude?
I got a lot of enemies. I've said some devices over the, over the year. So like,
it could be one of many, many people. If I had to be murdered,
who's the most likely suspect. Probably Burke Crusher's wife, Leanne. Um,
she has ample cause to hate man. Makes great jam though.
Would you rather give the first 90% of a blow job or the last 10%?
Would you rather get? Oh, I see time-wise.
Okay.
So now you've got to think this out because if I get the first 90% that's now
we're talking about,
it's probably going to be an overall at eight or nine minute blow job.
I don't have good technique job. Good skills. Obviously. I know what's good.
And I'll try to like work the balls a little bit. I'm not gonna be an about it.
You know? Why should they hate themselves? Just cause I'm gonna hate myself.
But the last 10% keep them out. I don't want to do the blow job the last 10%.
If you get somebody good in there,
we're talking about like 40 seconds and I'm down in the last 10 seconds.
So we're talking about, Oh, but then, Oh, I see why there's a funny,
the comment I throw up and I'm not one of those guys who are gonna like shoot it
on my. No, if I'm giving a blow job,
I'm taking it to the throat last 10%, just for the experience.
Just so I can know what women are going through for that hot load.
Don't need asparagus though, or anything like that, make it worse.
You're in an open field, armed with a baseball bat.
How many ten-year-olds wearing bike helmets.
Could you take down before they get to you? Okay.
This is a deeper question than it's actually asking.
Are these ten-year-olds trained?
Do they have someone guiding them or are they just randomly there?
And as they start beating them, they slowly have to come to terms with, Oh,
we got to get this guy before he keeps killing all of us.
I'm thinking the ladder. In which case it would be hundreds.
They don't organize. Well, they're not intelligent.
Ten-year-olds to say boys or girls. It doesn't really matter.
I'll beat the out of either one of them. It would be harsher if I it.
I imagine a little girl.
Remember that chick from game of Thrones where she's like awkward,
how much are out? Because I'm a recurrent character, idiots.
Imagine taking a baseball bat as someone cute like that.
And just crack where the thing is. You see them go and ends up moment. And then,
and then the fall let's set this game up actually.
Yeah. Oh.
Yeah. That'd be a pay-per-view for sure. Um, do to be hundreds,
it'd be hundreds. Even when they come close, I would do the jab straight in.
I would say run. If you want to live, make them all think they can run,
but I'm chasing them down with their short legs.
You don't think you'd have any like 10, 10 in like 10 murders and be like,
I can't do this anymore. I'm murdering these kids like mentally.
No, physically though. I'd have to rest. That's when they could get me.
But again, their ten-year-olds are not intelligent. They're not organized.
And parents they're on the phones now. So they're not like, you know,
teaching their kids anything.
Would you rather only watch soft core porn or minor league sports for the rest
of your life? Wait, I don't understand the question.
Forever. Every time you turn on board.
It's only softcore or sports only minor league sports. That's a tough one.
Probably a minor league sports at least say the love of the game.
And to be honest, even minor league, baseball's better than like w NBA,
which is pro they can dunk. Oh no,
no. I bought shop core porn because I. So like, it's not like I'm a, you know,
I'm not like I'm a 16 year old who can't get laid.
I can just find a chick who wins in a street fight street,
fight Mike Vick or Tim. Teebo interesting.
Timbo can call Jesus to his side. Jesus is not known as a warrior. However,
no, it'd be Michael Beck. What do you mean? But of course he might go back.
I was thinking like Michael Vick's age, but it wouldn't matter.
Michael Beck for sure. And then Michael Vick would Tim Tebow's hot wife.
If you could party with one sports team in history, who would it be?
The Miami hurricanes of the bad years. They own Miami, the Coke town,
the transsexual town. They owned it. It was theirs.
They went and wherever they want to,
where the they want that's I mean a sports team. I mean,
do you see the U it was the craziest thing in the world. They were the team,
obviously there's people. I like, you know, the, the mantle era, uh, Yankees,
but like, I'm talking about partying. Like I want Oh,
D with the Miami hurricanes. Well, you know, this is not the first time to,
you know, they'd be like, Oh, get the trade thing. And they would get in there.
They would have one ready dude. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. By the way, before I read this question,
I was a practice player for the university of Maryland women's basketball team.
For two years,
I practice with those bishops and I went easy on them for maybe 30 minutes
before they elbow mated the neck. And I'm like, we're going Bronco.
We're going to bench six foot nine. Um,
if you could have sex with any person you want at any time,
be can only watch women's sports forever. What'd you do it?
Why did the person do you want at any time? I mean,
Angelina Jolie and our prime will be pretty hot with Jennifer Aniston
watching. It's not in here. No it's sports socks, man.
It's getting better now than letting the transsexuals in.
They're actually starting to break some records, having a sport sports times,
but you can watch it. Yeah.
They need some people identifying as women to get into the NBA and actually show
some good dunks and. And once I got terrible at it,
that's only if you like women's sports, who's watching them. It's more,
it's the first place. You just feel bad for them. That's why,
if you can have one person narrate do play by play of you having sex.
Who would it be? Um, it wouldn't be what's his name?
He should have died a long time ago for college basketball. Dickie B.
Yeah. He's like the Howard stern now of it's just a shell of himself.
Um, no, I'm going to go outside the box.
Donald Trump is one of the funniest guys in the world and I think he would like
somehow figure out how to bring world politics into it. And it makes sort of,
sort of like metaphor, uh, for taking over the world. Dude, I went traveling.
The best thing was everybody's like, Oh, Americans are dead. I'm like, yeah,
Trump. What? Every time it was like, you shouldn't do that as dangerous.
Like Trump, what I can do what I want in a car chase with the police.
What song is playing in your car? Dude? You don't play music.
You just get the out of there. You don't stop and play with the radio.
Who's talking when I have these questions, internet use your brains, dude.
That's why you guys are failing. Well, Jesus succeeded.
That's why we plant and follow through with it. And like nine 11, we planned it.
We saw it. We made it happen. Oh, you guys didn't know about that. Oh,
can please edit that out? Sorry please. Responsible. Yeah,
I'll use that word. Responsible.
Responsible sounds a little like you're texting and something else happen to
someone else. I mean, planned it more than responsible. Yeah.
Executed is a good way to say it. Execute it. Yeah.
Follow the gold. Follow the gold. No Jews died in nine 11.
How do you explain that? How do you explain that? Not one.
Explain that then no one there's one,
because he thought he had time woods in tower one and tower two to end.
He went back in to close a deal and then ran out of time. Yeah.
You guys didn't know that nine 11. It was the Jews.
They communicated with those boxes in their heads. 30 midgets first,
a lion who wins that lion crushes. There's no question about it.
I've often thought about that.
Also pay-per-view $100 I would pay for that easily. I'd be charged 200.
I grumble about it and also pay
these minority midgets.
Or are these like sort of a diverse group of midgets or we have sorta like,
yeah, by the way, that almost happened when they were doing an original, um,
wizard of Oz thing where they were trying to have all the, uh,
and then after that did happen, he, this lion killed a bunch and they said, Hey,
how can we get a guy in a calorie line outfit instead of an actual lion?
Yeah. Towards the back in those days, majors didn't have many rights.
So they were like, Ooh, they felt bad, but no repercussions.
Would you rather prove aliens are real or prove ghosts, surreal,
uh, aliens. For sure. Ghosts don't do anything. Even if they're real. It's like,
okay, I guess there's spirits here, but still got to go to work.
So got to work on their resume. If aliens are real, should change it.
You can go places Hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy.
You can get out there and see the world. You think you're traveling well now,
like go to another galaxy dude.
Also alien sex would be great, but go sex would just be like,
you air would just be like, um, nah, I guess,
but this, you know, imagine like a vagina inside the vagina,
my mind in alien thing opened up and then like, yeah, yeah. But that with,
come on, you gotta try it. You have to at least try it and then be like,
and then there's a third mouth with like a teeth. And like, I'll just short.
I'll risk it. Who went to the street fight, Allen Iverson or yang dude.
I ran into yang at,
in Egypt at the pyramids. You can't miss him.
I would, you can't mess up. You see this tower. And you're like, what?
And it's like, Oh, that's y'all man. For sure.
And I was kind of walking past him. I was, I was photo bombing,
a bunch of pictures,
but there's almost all Chinese people that were also there touring,
which are the worst tourist. If you see any,
if you're anywhere in China as like a tour bus of Chinese group leave,
come back the next day or just don't do it. They will do it another trip. Um,
anyway, he was there.
I was trying to like photo bomb in the back to hopefully someone would like,
is that a tiny Orisha fear behind a giant y'all man can crush Allen Iverson who
crush Alzheimer's. And now that I'm thinking about it,
he would give him one of these and he would that's it. I don't know.
Obviously there's no, not to practice. And Yamin would practice for that fight.
Yeah. It'd be filming for sure. And then you have things he's old,
always got no legs. Allen's got the speed and agility.
He had the speed and agility and he still got more than two.
There was this move that I tried playing with.
Could we saw Iris do it when I was with the girls' basketball team and I
perfected it and ran it once where you, you start to do the three 60, right.
Dribble. But instead of that, as you do it, you throw the ball this way.
So as they come, cause you just, you have, it helps if you're slow.
Cause they think they can steal it when you would come in this way,
but you throw it this way. They catch nothing. And then you, Oh,
I did it once in a practice. Yeah. Coach Wella was like, stop practicing.
She goes, what was that? And I was like,
that was the Allen Iverson hall of fame coach stopped. I asked, I begged,
let me in one game, coach Weller. I painted my nails back then I had long hair.
I'm like just scrub time. Not real minutes. She said rules.
Would you wrap them? Imagine Johnson a regular me without AIDS. Well,
he doesn't have AIDS yet. As far as I know HIV,
but I see what you're side on here. Um,
magic Johnson or me with her it's well,
I hate the Lakers then my least favorite team.
I did like them in the magic Johnson days.
I think probably just me regular me, you know,
because of the AIDS I was stopped myself and I was thinking, well,
his age, he also wouldn't be able to do comedy. You know,
he was a failure now with the Lakers rebuilding with a prom,
but really it's sound to the AIDS. You know,
you get sidetracked sometimes with extra details, but that AIDS is like a,
I don't want to say deal breaker, but you know what I mean?
Like if you have a woman and like, who like, do I need to wear a condom?
She's like, um, maybe like, Oh, because you're unsure of herself. It's like,
and then like, yeah, no, I mean age like, Oh yeah.
Maybe I'll maybe I'll go back to Tinder and see what else is out there today.
I girls with herpes. I I'll slow, you know? So I don't get it, but like.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Yeah. Cause it's all scraping. So don't scrape. Just ease it in, make it happen.
Or I guess technically you could wear a condom,
but no one's looking for that. That's obviously that's obviously, yeah.
That's obviously a fantasy world. Uh, I am in between my mom and my dad.
My dad is, my dad is one inch inside of,
of my, my, uh, S
and I am one inch inside of my mother. Doesn't say which side of her I'm into,
but which way do I move forwards or backwards?
Oh, internet God, you guys, first of all, very creative. Always.
I think, Oh my God. I mean, there's, this is one of those no right.
Answer things.
I think I moved backwards into my dad because he survived the
Holocaust.
And if he gets survived that I feel like this would help me survive this.
But even in the Holocaust that didn't make that happen.
Internet has gone further than the Holocaust. Congratulations, internet,
ask questions. You.
I'm.
Not going to get out of my head anytime soon.
Okay.